[Music]  so how would you feel about going to the  Moundsville Christmas with grace she  really wants to get to know you guys  that's our mom's hat ah okay I don't  want to leave you here with the kids if  you're not feeling up talk yeah I'm  feeling fine it was my idea and it's a  couple days I can do a couple days  okay guys I'm off fun what is that  what surprised everyone committed  suicide so far  repent and you will find salvage things  are very uncomfortable opportunist and  we're stuck in a house together what is  this a pirate oh where are my face it  makes no sense what I heard something  [Music]  hello did you do that we didn't do  anything  [Applause]  we're leaving what are you talking about  look outside we're stuck here  [Music]  okay  trust me  you have nothing to be scared about  [Music]